welcome back to another Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast in
today's episode Greg and I field
listeners questions about branch chain
amino acids mini cuts potential
differences between males and females
tips for your first powerlifting meet
and more to finish off the episode Greg
and I discuss our favorite quad
exercises for building up big legs in a
big squat remember we have a new process
for submitting questions if you want
your questions answered on a future
episode submit them by visiting tiny dot
CC slash SBS QA or click on the link in
the episode description as always thank
you for listening and enjoy the show
welcome to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host Eric Trexler today I am joined by a
temporary guest host named Greg knuckles
and since it is a Q&A episode we are
gonna get right down to business so the
first question is for Greg it is from
John Haynes the question is how does
chronological age affect potential
training status yeah so first off thank
you for the question
Jon so Jon also asked another question
or submitted something else via our Q&A
forum to ask and verify that I am
actually originally from Knoxville North
Carolina he is one of maybe two thousand
other Mocksville lights out in the world
and so yes John I am originally from
Knoxville small world so anyway so
John's question was was how does age
affect potential training status and the
examples he gave were for example if
Arnold Schwarzenegger had started
training in his 30s or 40s would he
still have been able to achieve almost
as impressive of a physique as he did
when he was you know competing and
bodybuilding in his 20s and maybe early
30s
then with further context of when you
look at sarcopenia and just rates of
natural muscle loss over time doesn't
paint a pretty picture so you know I I'm
going to answer this question with the
assumption being the question is
if you compare two people they're
exactly the same maybe they're identical
twins and one of them Sario training
early in life and say one of them
started training in their 30s or 40s by
the time they're 50 how different will
their results be in terms of strength
and physique that that's going to be
kind of my assumption when answering the
question and the answer is we don't know
for sure but I think we can make some
educated guesses so to start with there
is bountiful evidence that older people
can still respond positively to
resistance training so there's a bunch
of studies with people in their 40s 50s
even into their 60s where they do a
resistance training program and they get
robust increases in muscle size and also
strength and disproportionate increases
in strength even relative to what you'd
see like in the strength versus muscle
mass increases in younger adults because
with sarcopenia you also get myopia
so not just a decrease in muscle mass
but also a further decrease in strength
disproportionate to the decrease in
muscle mass and it seems like a lot of
that disproportionate decrease in
strength that comes with age comes
roaring back when you expose people to
resistance training and they're like
muscle mass to strength ratio becomes
more normalized and more similar to what
it would be for a younger adults oh yeah
we see that older adults can respond and
not just older but middle-aged adults as
well still respond very robustly to
resistance training probably not quite
as much as you know teenagers or people
in their 20s do but still pretty large
response there there have been a couple
recent papers looking at resistance
training in very old adults so I believe
the the paper I saw recently the age
range was like 84 to 95 and there have
been a few other studies with people in
their 80s into their 90s where it seemed
like by the time you're that age you you
may you may realistically not get that
much out of resistance training you're
the the processes of citizens have you
know taken their toll to such a degree
that you just probably don't respond
super well to really probably any
exercise stimulus at that point but
that's you know they're we're talking
like very much end of life for pretty
much everyone except like super
centenarians but for the vast vast
majority of life you train good things
happen and so then the question is you
know how is that going to differ if you
pick up training in your 40s versus if
you started when you were younger and as
I said we don't have direct evidence for
that but I think it would probably be
pretty similar actually to aerobic
training and we discussed a study
previously on the stronger by science
podcast that looked at that and
basically so that study was comparing
groups of individuals who had been
engaged in endurance training their
entire lives versus groups of people who
picked up endurance training I believe
in their 40s and these folks in the
study were now in their 50s and 60s and
what they saw is that the folks who
picked up the endurance training in
their 40s were just as good of endurance
athletes as the people who had been
doing recreational endurance training
their entire lives I kind of assume the
same thing would be true for strength so
essentially if you you know if you start
doing resistance training both muscle
mass and strength go way above what
their baseline would have been if you
didn't train but then eventually age
catches up to everyone except maybe Dave
Rick's
you know time will tell if he's
squatting 800 on his 80th birthday maybe
he's the one exception but for the most
part time catches up with everyone and
even if you keep training you're gonna
get progressively weaker over time and
it's kind of a parabolic ish shape but
not exactly but it goes up and starts
trending down over time then if you
didn't resistance train when you were
young and started when you were in your
30s or 40s you're also going to get a
big spike up over a baseline in terms of
both both muscle mass and strength when
you start training and at some point
that that progression of strength and
muscle is probably going to more or less
catch up with where it would have been
if you'd been training the whole time so
you know and that may be like a 10-year
process so if you would have started
training in your 20s and in training the
whole time and instead you pick up
training at 35 then maybe you know you
at 40 compared to the theoretical you
that would have started training 15
years ago maybe at 40 you're still not
where you would have otherwise been at
40 but by the time you're 45 or 50
you're to basically the same place you
would have been had you been training
the whole time I think that that's
probably what would happen for the
majority of people however I do think
that I do think that there's probably
something to physical exercise and
specifically things that challenge the
muscles during childhood and adolescence
that probably make a pretty significant
difference in terms of long-term
capability so and again this this is
kind of my opinion I don't know of
direct research on this but just based
on what I've seen like I and this could
just be like selection bias that the
people who are naturally gifted for
lifting are also the people who are
naturally gifted enough for other sports
that they gravitate to them when they're
young but but I do kind of think that
like you know maybe you starting
training at 35 and you starting training
at 20 by the time you're 45 maybe you
wind up in basically the same spot but I
do think that you know you starting
training at 35 after a fairly sedentary
childhood versus you with a active
childhood playing sports growing up and
then picking up resistance training in
your 20s I think that that's probably
that that very well may give you a
lifelong
benefit above what you would have gotten
if you had a sedentary childhood I again
I I can't cite research to back that up
but that's that's very much what it
looks like to me when I just compare
people who did have active childhoods
and maybe did some manual labor like
working on farms or played a lot of
sports growing up like it really does
seem that they respond a lot better to
resistance training which again could
just be bias of they played sports
because they would have been naturally
gifted for strength in the first place
but I I do suspect that that may be an
actual effect but yeah for the most part
you're probably missing out on maybe a
little something during the first five
years that you're training but by the
time you've put ten years and under the
bar where you are at that point is
probably where it would have been at the
same chronological age if you had 30
years under the bar leading up to that
point I agree and this is this seems to
be a really common concern I feel like
we we tend to get a lot of questions of
people that are in one of two positions
either they've been training for a while
but they're approaching you know insert
your age here and they're concerned that
things are gonna start dropping off or
they're new to the game and they're you
know whatever age to them is potentially
problematic and they're like should I
even bother getting into this thing at
this point have I missed too much mm-hmm
and I feel like while I understand those
concerns for sure I do think a lot of
people maybe overestimate exactly how
how horrific we things drop off in the
30s 40s and 50s
you know you still see people in the 50s
in their 50s and sometimes even in the
60s that are doing some some pretty wild
stuff athletically and then when you
look at people in their 70s and 80s who
have continued their activity level
compared to their peers it's just
dramatically night and day so so I
always try to make a point to encourage
people like let's not worry about like
whether or not just everything's gonna
completely go downhill when you turn 40
you know because realistically there's
still
plenty of gas left in that tank and even
if you're not going to hit your you know
all-time peak physique at the age of 63
when you look around at your 63 year old
peers you're gonna be a heck of a lot
you're gonna be a much better shape and
very happy that you still decided to
pursue this stuff yeah for sure there
are two different considerations here
it's like you know one maybe
are you losing something over what would
have been theoretically optimal if you
started training twenty years ago I mean
maybe we don't know that for sure but
you know that's a possibility but then
kind of in terms of opportunity cost
moving forward would you be missing
something ten years from now if you
didn't start training today yes for sure
right and so the you you are absolutely
still going to get something out of it
maybe you're not going to reach the
heights that you would have otherwise
but you're still going to be way way
better off for for picking it up in the
first place definitely all right
question for Erich Fromm hi Otto
nishiyama I hear people talk about BCAAs
all the time
but I really don't hear people talk
about EAS or essential amino acids
essential amino acids are more expensive
than BCAAs but are they actually better
or is it a waste of money like BCAAs are
so this is a good question
definitely BCAAs have had their place
kind of up in the royal family of
supplements in the bodybuilding world or
at least they had I feel like they're
kind of lost that foothold but I don't
know why I'm not certain why the
branched chain amino acids rose to
prominence and the essential amino acids
didn't I think for a while there Greg am
I crazy for thinking that for a while
there there just weren't any decent
tasting EA formulas out there I feel
like there were potentially flavoring
issues that led people to go down the
the BCAA route I mean possibly
[Music]
I think a lot of that would probably
depend on leucine dosing because leucine
tastes terrible yeah yeah so I don't
know why the company's decided hey let's
go all in on on branch chains but
definitely if you looked at the market
just based on the products that were
available there is a lot more emphasis
on branch chains than essential amino
acids and just to kind of set the
framework here so the branch chain amino
acids are three amino acids that do
happen to be essential amino acids but
an essential amino acid product just has
the other essential amino acids as well
so the branch change our branch chains
are basically a subcategory of the
essential amino acids and then there are
also non-essential amino acids in the
diet now the reason the essential amino
acids are important is because if you
intend to do something crazy like build
some muscle proteins then you're gonna
need all the essential amino acids
present in sufficient quantities now as
the asker of the question alluded to the
the the more popular opinion these days
is that branched chain amino acid
products probably have a lot more
limited utility than we used to think or
them we then used to be kind of commonly
thought so back in the day I mean you
were not gonna find a bodybuilder that
wasn't carrying around a gallon jug full
of unusually purple water and without
question the reason it was purple was
because there are branch chain amino
acids in it and they would basically
just sip on it all day like a leucine
drip and I think a lot of people were
really into this idea and by the way
leucine is one of the branch chain amino
acids but I think a lot of people were
really into this idea that if you just
kind of consistently sipped on branch
chains that it's like okay we're gonna
stay slightly anabolic like pretty much
around the clock and with what we've
learned about the temporal aspects of
muscle protein synthesis and muscle
protein breakdown that doesn't seem to
be a good strategy so the people that
were putting a lot of
in that basket I mean their water tasted
better than it otherwise would have in
most cases but aside from that it
probably wasn't doing a ton for them and
to be honest I just can't think of a
super great use for a branched chain
amino acids I can think of maybe some
uses for essential amino acids but
really what we're getting at here with
using an essential amino acid supplement
may be you could argue that if someone
was on a let's say like a vegan diet on
fairly limited calories so they couldn't
want one of the tricky things about
vegan diets is you have to make sure
that you're getting enough protein
intake that you know by putting all
these different protein sources together
you're getting the essential amino acids
you need throughout the day and one of
the challenges with that is finding
vegan proteins that have diverse amino
acid profiles that don't also have a
decent amount of fat or carbohydrate in
them and so it can get pretty tough
without supplementation to put together
a low-calorie high-protein vegan diet it
can get really challenging without
question now if you choose to consume a
vegan diet I got zero problems with that
totally fine with that
but there are some challenges there when
it comes to meeting those those needs
for amino acid intakes so I could maybe
see the utility of an essential amino
acid product in that context maybe like
I know one way that people like to use
this is for an intra workout kind of
deal where they're like oh I want to
have intra workout protein but in order
to make digestion a little easier maybe
a and maybe you know uptake quicker
absorption maybe I'll go with essential
amino acids I guess if you're comparing
it kind of apples to apples they're the
essential amino acids probably would
make more sense but I think there's a
very limited number of people who really
need to be having intra workout protein
supplementation so even with that
justification I don't think it's a
particularly I don't think you're likely
to see a very big benefit from that
personally maybe if you are about to do
a pretty intense workout and you're like
you know what I don't want to go in
there completely fasted I'd like to have
some amino acids some kind of some kind
of amino acids in the bloodstream during
and then immediately after the workout
if maybe if you wanted to do that but
you couldn't eat a full protein a full
in prep intact
food based protein because it just your
stomach cannot handle digesting those
proteins during the workout maybe there
might be an application there but the
one thing I want to highlight is as you
can imagine these scenarios that I'm
constructing for trying to find a really
good valve
really good justified use for them you
have to start putting kind of like a few
circumstantial factors together to make
these scenarios I I personally think
that the the supplementation
I think the promise of branched-chain
and essential amino acid supplementation
is very limited to very specific
specific circumstances at best I I can I
can throw an out there that I do think
applies to probably a non-negligible
amount of people sure what do you got so
I think that um I think that there's
been a lot of backlash against BCA's
probably to a degree that's not
completely warranted because the thing
is I think a lot of the backlash is they
were so hyped a few years ago and now
there are more and more researchers
coming in and we realize like the the
level of hype we saw probably wasn't
justified but the thing is there is a
lot of research on branch chains and to
a lesser degree essential amino acids
which probably are just as good as
branch chains if not slightly better but
there there is a fair amount of work on
branch chain amino acids looking at
recovery from resistance training to the
point that there is a few meta analyses
at this point
and those metas do find that
compared to a placebo which is almost
always multi dextran branched-chain
amino acids do improve recovery from
from exercise training and so the
problem is that even though there's I
don't know probably 15 or 20 studies at
this point comparing branch chains to a
placebo they've never been compared to
just like straight up whey protein to
see the effects on recovery from
resistance exercise and in all
likelihood like I mean we know protein
does the same stuff you give people
protein versus a placebo protein also
improves recovery from resistance
exercise and so in all likelihood
branched chain amino acids don't do any
better than protein and and very well
could be worse than protein for recovery
from resistance exercise so that's like
a glaring hole in the literature but one
thing to note just from a practical
perspective is that a lot of people and
myself included here so I don't use
branched chain amino acids but I kind of
think I probably should because I don't
want to eat directly after a workout I
kind of get around that because I'm one
of the weird people who can eat a lot
right before a workout and I'm totally
fine but especially with using protein
supplements if I use particularly whey
protein within an hour of finishing a
training session it always makes me feel
nauseated and you know if I'm hot and
like a little overheated from a training
session I don't want to immediately go
home and eat a huge meal like I probably
don't really want to eat again until
maybe two two-ish hours after a training
session and so in my case if I would be
comparing branched chain amino acids
against nothing branch chain amino acids
very well might help me I don't use them
because I cheat us [ __ ] but but I I
dunno and this is feedback I've heard
from a lot of people when I have [ __ ] on
branched chain amino acids in the past
where they're like I just can't consume
protein around workouts like it always
makes me feel really nauseated I don't
have much of a nap
tight but I can sip on branch chain
amino acids and that's totally fine
and so like I don't think that that
applies to a large majority of people
but if you do compare branch chains
against nothing it is it is better than
nothing like that is something you can
confidently say about it so if you're
someone who just just doesn't want to
consume protein around a training
session because it's like upsets your
stomach makes you feel nauseated you
probably will get some utility from
branch chain amino acid supplementation
yes I did mention that scenario in the
pre exercise context but I didn't think
about the post because that's never been
a problem for me I'm the opposite I
struggled to Train on a full stomach but
right after I can eat usually yeah
but that would make sense in that
scenario I would speculate that in
essential amino acid product if I'm I
would speculate would probably be even a
better option no I agree then branch
chain amino acids so so to answer the
question I would say it most the places
where you can really justify using
either branch chains or essential amino
acids I do think that you would at least
be inclined to slightly have a more
favorable view of the essential amino
acids because I just think there's
inherent benefit to having a more
complete amino acid profile than just
the branch chains in that supplement so
you know the two most likely scenario is
playing the numbers as we mentioned you
don't have the stomach for having whole
intact proteins that require greater
digestion
you know before after a workout or you
are consuming a diet that is most mostly
plentiful in lower quality proteins so
I'm thinking usually a vegan diet and
you are simply using it to supplement
the amino acid profile of some of those
lower quality proteins I do want to
bring I want to like limp into the the
discussion here with a couple like takes
that I'm not fully committed to
so a couple recent things that are just
my bias generally speaking is to lean
toward food when food can work and then
when it can't work then embrace
supplementation so I'm not anti
supplement by any means but you know for
me I'm always thinking what is it gonna
take to shift me away from a food and
toward a supplement or if a supplement
just cannot be obtained from food then
that decision is easy but with amino
acids I'm always thinking why am I not
gonna have a delicious hamburger and
instead I'm going to have some kind of
weird amino acid mixture replacing food
and so or a weird and sad simulacrum of
lasagna potentially that's we'll talk
about that later so there was a review
paper by a few authors that I would just
mispronounce all of their names young
queen who you long in and woo but this
paper came out in 2015 if you want to
search it maybe we'll go with the title
not the author names that I just there's
no way you could possibly figure out how
to spell those dietary essentiality of
nutritionally non-essential amino acids
for animals and humans and basically
what they were highlighting in the paper
is that non-essential amino acids do
play important roles and things like
gene expression cell signaling digestion
absorption DNA and protein synthesis
protein metabolism endocrine status a
whole bunch of things that that several
non-essential amino acids play very
critical roles and and what what the
general argument they were making is is
that the extreme focus and emphasis on
essential amino acids in the diet has
may be undersold the role that dietary
non-essential amino acids play so so
they're basically saying hey by calling
them non-essential we've really we've
really downplayed exactly exactly how
important it is to get some of these
amino acids from the diet there was also
a very interesting paper in 2019
this one was called branched-chain amino
acids impact health and lifespan
indirectly via amino acid imbalance or I
guess it's amino acid balance and
appetite control but when you read the
paper they're really focused on
imbalance but what they were doing it
was a rodent study and they basically
looked at these rats or mice and they
tweaked the the branch chain amino acid
content of their diets and because
there's long been this kind of weird
observation that high branch chain amino
acid intake seems to be associated with
like diabetes and and insulin resistance
and so the question is what's what
exactly is going on there because it's
just an association not necessarily a
causal relationship so a lot of times
people see those associations and they
say like oh branch chains are gonna give
me diabetes but what what they found
with their study against one study it's
a rodent model we don't know exactly how
well it's gonna translate over to humans
I'm by no means an amino acid metabolism
expert but what they found was that when
they really ramped up the branch chain
amino acid content of the diets what
they found was they basically in an
induced in imbalance between the branch
chain amino acids and essentially all
the other dietary amino acids that would
be taken in and the ones that they
really focused in on were tryptophan and
3 and threonine and what they found was
that this was associated with hyper
Faiza which is an increased appetite and
central serotonin depletion what they
were getting at is that by drastically
increasing the branch chain amino acid
content of a diet maybe by inducing this
imbalance that would not typically be
found in the normal protein sources of
the diet for these animals
maybe that imbalance was true triggering
hyperphagia and some other unwanted kind
of unintended consequences of altering
that balance that caused them to
essentially overeat
I don't again I mean completely limping
in with very not strong takes on this
but there are at least some kind of
rumblings in the literature that would
make you think kind of they basically
support my
is that I came to the conversation with
with which is basically you have to
convince me to move away from food
toward amino acid supplementation or at
least give me good reason to believe
that these are truly equivalent things
that are worth swapping so aside from
the very special because the reason I
bring this up is everyone's always like
yeah but what if I had this awesome
extremely supercharged diet that has
like all these very complex like I'm
supplementing you know all these
different amino acids at all these
different times because this is better
than just a standard diet with plenty of
protein in it I have some reservations
about getting super complicated about
all these different dosing protocols for
different amino acid mixtures I think
for me right now unless you're in some
of those really specialized scenarios
that we talked about where we're like
okay it makes a lot of sense to put in
like branch chains or essential amino
acids barring those circumstances we
already kind of put forward I think
generally speaking if you're having a
diet with sufficient protein that's got
plenty of high quality protein sources
in it most of your amino acid needs are
going to be met and really not worth
getting too concerned about one thing I
would add about the the rodent study is
I don't know if the finding of BCA
induced hyper fascia has been replicated
in humans but the depletion of
tryptophan and the CNS and the the
decrease in serotonin production I'm
quite confident that there is evidence
for that in humans as well that's that's
one of the things I came across when I
used to have much more sleep issues than
I did and I was looking into like oh
what are some of the things
nutritionally I could do to to maybe
sleep a little bit better and one of the
things that a lot of people were
recommending is maybe don't eat protein
right before bed if you're having sleep
issues like for the vast majority of
people it's it's it's probably not going
to affect you but
maybe if you are having sleep issues
like eating like high leucine protein
sources can deplete tryptophan in the
brain to some degree because if memory
serves leucine and tryptophan have the
same transporter and so it's like a
competitive inhibition thing and
tryptophan helps with relaxation and
getting to bed so I don't know if if the
hyper fascia bit has been replicated in
humans but I think the general
physiology has been has been shown to
apply to humans as well so it may be
applicable yeah I believe there are some
papers looking at because of the kind of
central neurotransmitter effects that we
see with like high branch chain amino
acid intakes I believe that there are
some studies looking at it as a means of
reducing central fatigue during like low
intensity exercise have you ever seen
those papers no I think they're out
there but but I remember it was looking
at like pretty low intensity long
duration stuff if memory serves so
adenosine I didn't get super into the
literature but I do believe it's out
there okay next question is for Greg
from Manas the question is most research
uses men as a sample population do you
think that the findings apply to women
in equal measure
so generally yes and at the very least I
think that I think that if if something
has been found to be true in men it's a
useful null to assume that it would
apply in women as well so for the most
part the the differences we see at least
in in here I'm talking like exercise
literature so for example I know that
it's been an issue in the medical
research in recent years are like oh
sometimes like certain diseases or
conditions don't manifest the same way
in men and women and maybe we've been
under diagnosing women for a lot of
years because we were looking for signs
that we had only like verified and male
research and I know that like hard
sar a big one there that like sometimes
the signs of heart attacks and men and
women are a bit different
and maybe like some drugs have different
effects on men and women are like
different interactions so anyway I'm not
trying to claim that this is like a
generalizable thing for all areas of
scientific research but at least for
exercise and nutrition research it seems
like most of the stuff that applies in
men probably applies to women as well
maybe with some slight differences but
not tremendous differences so for
example some of the differences that we
have seen in some of which we've talked
about on the podcast before is that men
and women may handle alcohol a little
bit differently such that at a given
dose of alcohol relative to body mass or
lean mass there may be an initial larger
spike in BAC in females but then they
metabolize it quicker and get it out of
their system a little bit quicker than
males do Eric reviewed a paper for the
upcoming issue of mass this month
talking about maybe some differences in
nitrate metabolism and perhaps the
efficacy of like beetroot
supplementation in males and females the
idea being that that maybe nitrate
supplementation when it helped females
quite as much due to various reasons but
one of which is just higher levels of
nitrite in the blood naturally and so
like maybe adding a little bit extra to
the mix doesn't really help all that
much and there there are obviously sex
differences in general as well so we
know that there's metabolic differences
in submaximal exercise so like females
rely a little bit more on oxidative
metabolism and males a little bit more
on anaerobic metabolism so like I I'm
I'm not trying to say that there are no
differences whatsoever but in terms of
research looking at application of say
different nutritional interventions or
different training protocols things seem
to be pretty similar and even when they
differ they
don't differ hugely so for example one
way that or like one area where some of
the research findings differ between
research on males and females is in
middle aged populations does resistance
training and plyometric training
increase bone mineral density until
recently it was thought that in
postmenopausal women
you couldn't increase bone mineral
density now now there have been a few
studies showing small increases but
still not huge increases whereas for
male populations of the same age you do
often see increases in bone mineral
density with resistance or plyometric
training so there that's a difference
but it's also it's a difference in
degree in not in kind because for
example for males of that age maybe
you're going to see a maintenance of
bone mineral density or a slight
decrease without training and now you're
seeing increases with training for women
maybe you're seeing decreases and maybe
even larger decreases without training
and with training you're seen
maintenance so it's still like better
than the alternative like the actual
outcome like whether it increases or
just holds its ground may differ but in
terms of is it better than not doing
this training it's still the same so
like you'll sometimes see differences
like that which maybe exist but aren't
functionally all that important for like
what you would actually recommend to
people and then just in terms of like
pure training research the stuff we've
seen work for for men works for women as
well and the like so there's in general
in the resistance training research more
research in in males and females but in
the handful of studies that do use
female subjects we tend to see similar
similarities or differences with various
protocols and males and females so for
example the periodization research way
way more research on males and females
but the
handful of studies in females also tend
to find periodized resistance training
produces larger strength gains than non
periodized not a huge body of research
but what we have looks similar to what
we've seen in males the the one area
where it kind of looked like it might be
different is in comparing high load and
low load training at one point there
were like 13 studies in males and 1 in
females and the studies and males we're
looking like Oh probably pretty similar
hypertrophy between high load and low
load training the one study and female
showed way more hypertrophy with with
heavier training but since then like 3
or 4 more papers have been published in
females looking at that question and
they all found pretty similar
hypertrophy with high and low load
training so kind of looked like that one
study may have been a bit of an outlier
but but yeah so I certainly don't want
to say that there are no differences but
the differences that do exist tend to
not be tend to not be like night and day
differences and I think that based on
the research we have so far it's
generally not a bad null hypothesis that
if we see something working in males
it's probably going to work in females
as well that's not always the case all
the time but when there are differences
they tend to be you know stuff like
increases versus maintenance and bone
mass that are still better than the
alternative
and and oftentimes aren't big enough to
really write home about yeah I mean it
is it is interesting though to see in
some cases how big the discrepancy can
be like you mentioned in the article I'm
working on for mass like they found like
a hundred relevant studies over 100 in
males only and then seven in females
like right yeah sometimes it can be such
a huge discrepancy and it's very
interesting to see how the magnitude of
some of these effects can change and
then taking a step further how it can
even vary throughout the menstrual cycle
in you men re-equipment so it's it's
it's really nice that that body of
literature seems to be growing very
aggressively over the last five or ten
years
like we finally were just like hey we
also need to study women too and yeah
it's been t I mean yeah I feel like
every month when we look at the new the
new batch of studies that came out
there's several studies looking at sex
differences which is which is awesome
yeah and one just general thing I would
add is kind of painting in broad strokes
here is that a lot of the differences
that exist and are noteworthy for
exercise you tend to be metabolic
differences and so but stuff like you
know just straight-up
muscle function and muscle metabolism
and like neural stuff tends to be pretty
similar or like quite quite similar
between males and females so in general
if there's say nutrition research or
supplement research that's only been
conducted in males and hasn't been
conducted and females do to those
metabolic differences and like
differences in how males and females
process certain nutrients and metabolize
certain things I would I would maybe be
a little bit more cautious and skeptical
of sports nutrition and sports
supplementation research if you if
you're only seeing findings in male
subjects whereas just straight-up like
sports science exercise research I think
that that's going to be quite quite
similar between males and females I
think in in both cases the similarities
are going to be larger than the
differences but the differences tend to
show up and maybe be more notable in
magnitude for nutrition and
supplementation stuff than just
straight-up exercise research and
especially like strength and hypertrophy
stuff that makes sense alright next
question is from baruk addressing this
to dr. Trexler he notes that Greg can
chime in as well but looking at the
topic of the question I am NOT going to
chime in as well so the question is what
is your opinion on mini cuts during an
extended gaining phase how long should a
mini cut be how aggressive should they
be and what should training be like in a
miny cut yeah it's a good question now
I've never been particularly fond of
many cuts but that doesn't mean that I
don't think they're okay
so what I mean by that is there are some
reasons to do many cuts but I've never
been of the opinion that you should like
plan out a weight gaining phase and be
like okay I'm gonna you know bulk for 12
weeks and then have a planned mini cut
for four because I'd say well why don't
why don't you just take a lower like a
slower rate of weight gain for those 16
weeks instead of you know taking some
very ambitious steps forward and then
taking time to take steps backward the
goal here is to put on some lean tissue
I think we should spend that time in a
surplus so there there are reasons
though why during a weight gaining phase
you might take you know take a minute to
reassess and say hey it's time for a
mini cut so you know if you get to a
point when when you're gaining weight
and you become unhappy with how you look
and you're like you know what I'd feel a
lot better if I continued this weight
gain phase but from a leaner spot which
is a totally justifiable perspective to
have or you could be unhappy with how
you feel you know you might you might
like have one of those days where you
like walk up a staircase and you're like
you know that that that was too hard it
shouldn't be that hard and then you
might say yeah I kind of want to trim up
a little bit and then reassess the or
kind of reinitiate the muscle gain phase
you know you might be unhappy with some
health markers you might go to the
doctor and be like ooh those numbers
aren't great or you might find that you
know based on the type of performance
you value that your weight gain has
maybe had an unfavorable effect on your
performance and you want to alleviate
that so there are reasons to do it but
but I also I'm not a huge fan of the
idea that it should be a pre-planned
scheduled in part of the weight gain
process I don't think that makes a lot
of sense to me now let's say you get to
that point you say for one of those
reasons or for some reason I didn't
think of it's time for a mini cut
honestly I would treat it basically
exactly like a regular normal cut so I
would focus in on what I would deem to
be an appropriate rate of of weight loss
generally speaking that's gonna be
somewhere between 0.5 to 1 percent of
body weight per week and part of the
question was you know how long should
the mini cut be I'd say work backwards
start with what's my intended rate of
weight loss
get on that rate of weight loss and then
however many weeks it takes that's how
many weeks you do you know you you focus
on maintaining the rate of weight loss
that seems appropriate and when you're
there when you're at the finish line
you'll know it and that's how long it
should take now when you're on a mini
cut I really don't think that you should
have to adapt your training too much you
you might have a natural urge to kind of
dive in and kind of overdo it with
cardio I think that would be inadvisable
the whole premise of a mini cut would
suggest this really doesn't have to be
an extreme measure you should be at a
place where you have plenty of fat to
lose which is why we're doing them any
cut in the first place
I mean you know plenty of fat to lose is
a very subjective term but you're not
like at the end of a very long weight
loss diet I mean this should not be a
particularly arduous task to do a mini
cut at the stage in which you're
initiating the cut so you shouldn't have
to make any really drastic changes you
shouldn't have to overdo it with the
cardio you really won't have to worry
you really shouldn't have to worry about
metabolic metabolic adaptation much at
all the nature of a mini cut would
suggest that you have some weight to
lose you're not in a rush to do it so
you should be able to take an
appropriate rate of weight loss in an
appropriate timeline and so you
shouldn't you shouldn't be pushing into
like super low body fat levels or losing
enormous amounts of weight so metabolic
adaptation really shouldn't be a
critical factor here aside from just
some
people need to drop their initial
calories just a little lower than others
if you are going to adapt something in
your training we had a really nice talk
with the other Eric Eric Helms about
this on the podcast generally speaking
when you're cutting and you need to
adapt your training the easiest things
to cut the most advisable things to cut
would be some of that just annoying
accessory volume that deep down in your
heart you know it's not it's not really
bringing that much to the table it's
just giving you more to recover from and
kind of stealing more minutes of your
time at the gym so dropping some
annoying accessory volume and I would
say to take that a step further just
dropping extraneous sets from that
volume so if the option is to trim down
the number of sets on to exercises or to
drop one entirely and leave the sets
alone on the other I would argue there
might be a slight advantage to just
trimming the sets for each because I
think what you see and Greg you know a
lot more about this than I do
just based on your your research
interests but you know going from one
sets to three sets
tends to be a positive thing but
eventually there's diminishing returns
where it's like you could probably trim
back on sets a little bit and still have
a really nice workout keeping your total
number of exercises in there but I mean
really there shouldn't be any huge
dramatic changes because the nature of
many cuts is such that this is not a
huge dramatic thing when you basically
you've got to you've gotten to a point
you've arrived at a point in your weight
gain phase where you say and we've kind
of gone a little overboard and you know
basically you you find yourself in a
spot where you do wish to continue
gaining lean mass but you know in some
cases we expect that there's going to be
some residual fat gain along with our
gain of lean mass whenever we do a
weight gain phase and if you get to a
point where you're like okay this is
definitely as as fat as I would like to
become at any point but I still have
lean mass to gain that's kind of a final
reason where it would make sense
to do a mini cut and say I know that
during the rest of this quest to gain
lean mass I'm gonna have some fat mass
gained with it but at the current rate
at my current ratio of fat mass to lean
mass that's gonna put me at a total
amount of fat mass that I'm really just
uncomfortable with so that that's
another scenario where it makes sense to
kind of recalibrate that balance of lean
mass to fat mass get a little bit leaner
so that you're like okay now when I
project the rest of this weight gain
phase I have a decent idea of how much
fat and lean mass I'll gain the
proportion there and now I feel like
I'll be in a much better spot when I
finish this weight gain phase so just to
tie that all up and put it all in a
concise conclusion it should not really
take a lot of drastic action it should
be treated basically like you're going
to begin a normal cut you just end it
way earlier you know the end point is
not the same we're not trying to get
shredded with it we're trying to just
get to a more manageable level of body
fat so you basically in my opinion treat
it like a normal cut you should not have
to worry about any dramatic changes in
training dramatic changes in diet
certainly metabolic adaptation should
not be at the forefront of your mind for
that type of a cut and then once you get
to a body fat that you feel a lot better
about now it's time to gain some weight
again make sense to me ok question for
Greg from Alex oh this is question for
both of us but again I'm just gonna shut
up know my place in this one and let
Greg talk so Alex asks us do either of
you have any recommendations for someone
going into their first powerlifting meet
yeah absolutely so if you are
considering signing up for your first
meet you've been training for
powerlifting for a while and are
considering should I compete or not I
think absolutely you should I think that
one for the most part meats are pretty
fun you're probably gonna enjoy doing it
and that will probably help you stick
with powerlifting which
my biases that it's probably a good
thing to stick with and then to I think
that there's a fringe benefit to signing
up for a meet in that it gives you it
gives you direction and drive in your
training so it's not terribly uncommon
to you know just kind of futz around
with your training and then realize like
oh it's been six months I haven't
actually made any progress and maybe
because I was doing things that were
dumb or lackadaisical whereas if you
know that you know on this date three
months from now I'm going to be
competing and it sure would be nice to
be stronger than than I am now to make
sure I'm getting my money's worth I
think that you know that helps keep you
focused and driven on it on a day to day
basis in the gym so anyway one if you're
if you're considering going into your
first powerlifting meet I would I would
strongly encourage you do so and then in
terms of advice and recommendations
going into it one I would recommend not
cutting weight your first meet is just
about getting a total on the platform
getting used to the process of competing
getting a little experience with that
it's a little bit stressful for for a
lot of people the first time that they
you know compete in a new sport so I
don't see any purpose and adding extra
stress on top of that by trying to cut
weight and also I mean just straight up
if we're being honest your first meet
you're probably not that good of a power
lifter yet so you know no one's going to
care if you put up a not incredibly
competitive total in you know the one
eighty one class versus the 165 class
like it's it's fine
don't cut weight just roll in at
whatever your normal body weight is and
then as you keep competing if you do
become more competitive over time then
you can start thinking about cutting
weights to you know pursue a particular
placing or maybe like a state record or
qualifying for Nationals but for your
first meet don't cut weight
one thing that I would strongly
recommend you do though is to practice
the commands in training this probably
works best if you have an in-person
coach or if you have training partners
who can do the commands for you make
sure you know what commands your
Federation has mainly I'm thinking if
you're competing USA PL or like IPF
Affiliate versus non IPF Affiliate here
the biggest difference is whether
they're going to have a start command
for the benchpress IPF affiliates do
most other Federation's don't but you
know make sure when you walk out for the
squat you're waiting for the squat
command you're waiting for the rack
command for the benchpress possibly
waiting for the start command certainly
knowing to wait for the press command
and for the deadlift knowing to wait for
the down command that jumping commands
gets a lot of lifters period but
certainly gets a lot of new lifters
because even if you've practiced you
know squatting to depth and pausing your
bench presses if you're not used to
waiting for commands and you jump a
command you could very well get red
lights for a lift that you did earn so
you know practice the commands if the
very least do it in your head or if you
have a training partner who can tell you
squat at the start of each squat single
that you do in prep for the meet you
know take advantage of that rack
commands etc so practice the commands
don't don't get red lights for silly
stuff another thing that I would
strongly recommend you do is to get
video of squat depth set up the camera
at around hip height or slightly below
dead on to the side ninety degree angle
don't rely on your training partners
unless your training partners compete in
the same Federation as you and know what
kind of squat depth judges look for so
if you're taking the video dead-on from
the side look and see you know is the
crease of my hip below the top of my
knee and yeah I mean I see a lot of new
lifters it's their first or second meet
and you know their technique is fairly
decent but they just squat a little bit
high and they're they're just caught
with their pants down because they they
don't know how deep you have to get to
get white lights and a powerlifting meet
and they're you know just taken aback by
having to squat three or four inches
deeper than they typically do in
training so make sure you get those
videos and make sure your squats are
actually to depth be prepared for a long
pause in case your judge is like the
head judge for bench presses super
strict or maybe just having a bad day
this I think is something else that gets
a lot of again a lot of lifters period
but certainly a lot of new lifters you
practice pausing your bench and training
but you know typically you don't have
someone giving you a press command and
you pause the bench for about half a
second the bar becomes motionless you
press it up things are good
you roll up on meat day and the judge is
just having a bad day and the press call
takes two seconds and suddenly bench
presses a lot harder and maybe your
openers a little bit too aggressive and
now you're in a world of suck and you
bomb on the bench press so I'm gonna
talk about openers soon but just I mean
in general be prepared for a longer
pause on bench press then you've you
think you're going to have to deal with
most judges are fine as soon as the bars
motionless you get the press command
everything's okay but don't be don't be
taken off-guard if you have a judge
giving really really long press calls
just make sure you know you do some like
three-second pauses in training and
whatever your opener is it's something
you can comfortably press with a really
long pulse so on then on the topic of
openers open really conservatively
if you're someone who has competed a lot
and you know you can be a little bit
more aggressive with your openers you
you really have your form dialed in with
heavier loads that's totally fine for
your first meet though priority number
one is you don't want to bomb out so be
conservative with your openers like
really do the
general advice I give lifters is if you
don't know what to open with open with
something you can do for a really
comfortable triple for your first meet I
would say open with something you can do
for a comfortable set of five you should
not miss that on the platform even if
maybe your your depth is off and you
find out you have to squat three inches
deeper than you're used to whatever you
can do for a set of five you should
still be able to get in for a single to
stay in the meet so so start with really
conservative openers for your first meet
something non competition related is
meats or long bring snacks you'll you'll
probably get hungry at some point during
the day something that I occasionally
see as people don't come prepared with
snacks that they know sit well on their
stomach and so you know maybe they use
like uber eats or like run out to a gas
station eat something and now their
stomachs kind of churning and deadlift
is coming up and they don't want to poop
themselves on the platform and that's
that's just not a good scenario
all-around so you know you're probably
gonna get hungry at some point during
the day after you make weight which
again I don't recommend cutting weight
but if you don't take my advice and you
do cut weight after you've made weight
like doesn't matter what you weigh
anymore bring snacks that you know are
gonna sit well on your stomach because
you will get hungry and you want to be
prepared and also bring drinks doesn't
hurt to have plenty of caffeine but also
just you know make sure you have a water
bottle there may or may not be water
fountains at the venue there will
certainly be bathrooms just bring a
water bottle that you can keep full and
then two more things one is make sure
you check the Federation's equipment
rules and and it's not a bad idea just
to scan the rule book in general but one
of the specific things to look for is
what the the Federation's rules are for
equipment in general you're gonna need a
regulation singlet depending on what
Federation you compete in again here I'm
thinking the IPF an IPF affiliates they
have specific manufacturers that they've
approved singlets for or wrist straps
for knees
leaves four so just make sure that all
of the gear you bring to the meet is
stuff that is allowed by the Federation
I actually got caught by this one time
because when I competed way back in the
day it wasn't standard to have equipment
rules for long socks you could just you
know where whatever socks you wanted and
they you know they have people on the
platform to keep the deadlift bars clean
and you know you would generally try to
not scrape your shin but if you did you
get some blood on the bar someone would
run on the platform clean the bar off
everything was fine then I rolled up to
a meet one time and they were like where
are your socks I'm like I'm wearing them
and they're like no wear your long
deadlift socks and I didn't have them so
I had to borrow them from another lifter
and so it was just like two people
sharing one pair of socks for the day
which is a little gross when it
necessarily recommended so make sure you
have long socks but one more thing on
the equipment side when I went to my
first meet they were like hey what are
you gonna wear under your singlet I'm
like just my underwear and they're like
you're not wearing that so they were
just boxer briefs and I guess in some
federations you can't do that either
right oh yeah I almost forgot about that
so that's that's something that's
changed just in the last few years but
yeah so you can't wear like Under Armour
shirts they think that you know maybe
you could slit the back and it would
just be like the world's weakest bin
shirt and you could get maybe five
pounds out of it and you can't wear a
boxer briefs because theoretically your
boxer briefs could be made of a thick
material and be super tight and function
kind of like squat briefs that you might
get again like five pounds out of so
yeah make sure if and I think this would
probably be a factor for male lifters
more than female lifters but make sure
you got some tighty whities or just
plain old boxers because in a lot of
feds these days boxer briefs don't count
anymore and I don't think they let you
free ball it on the platform either so
make sure yeah make sure you have
tighty-whities or boxers
okay so equipment rules last thing is
make friends powerlifting meets can be
fun but they are long it's a really good
idea if you go to a gym where other
people compete it's a really good idea
just to to go to a meet that other
people from your gym are doing so you
know then you can hang out with friends
all day it's a blast it can be a little
bit more weird and lonely if you know
you're the only person you know that's
competing but if that is the case power
lifters are an accepting bunch like 98%
of lifters if you know you're you're in
the warm-up room and you're on the rack
next to them and you let them know it's
your first meet there they're probably
gonna take you under their wing you know
give you some advice for the day be your
friend for the day and you know you can
make you can make good connections if
you're not super integrated into the
powerlifting scene in your area
talk to a bunch of people at the meet
make some friends you can find some
training partners
I mean powerlifting is just filled with
like [ __ ] and drama online but in person
it's a big happy family
so take advantage of that when you're
you know at a meet venue with a bunch of
other power lifters make a bunch of
friends we're all we're all crazy in
similar ways and if the sport of
powerlifting appeals to you we are
probably weird in a similar way that you
are weird and we're we're good friends
to have so make friends it's so weird
how that happens we're like you know the
same thing with like bodybuilding the
internet it just seems like a highly
contentious place and then you go to a
meet and or a meter a competition
everybody's just super friendly
everybody has so much in common they
just want to be friends I did have one
question so sometimes people find the
warmup process a little bit difficult to
navigate basically trying to time their
warmup trying to make sure they have
access to equipment for equipment for
the warm-up and then like I said time in
relation to their placement in their
flight mm-hmm is there anything useful
you can tell a first-timer or just
expect the unexpected
yeah man it
so that's tough the reason I didn't say
anything about warm-ups is that it does
vary so much venue to venue so some
warm-up rooms are gonna have you know
plenty of racks plenty of bars
absolutely no problem to get warmed up
the meats running on schedule when they
say your flights gonna start in 30
minutes your flight you know starts in
31 minutes and you know everything's
running smoothly and then some meats
it's a [ __ ] and there's virtually
no equipment in the warm-up room you
know they say your flights about to
start in 30 minutes and it starts in 10
and then for the deadlift they say it's
gonna start in 30 minutes and then bench
runs long and it starts in an hour
so yeah warming up properly ironically
is often times more stressful than the
actual lifts you put on the platform
because you're like can I get equipment
can I actually get warmed up in time so
what I would recommend is like yeah if
it's your first meet one of the reasons
I said make friends is that if someone
else is there and it's their tenth meet
they've probably dealt with warm-up [ __ ]
before and they've probably done like
whatever meet you're doing they probably
held the same meet in the same venue
last year and if they if they're doing
the meet this year they probably did the
meet last year as well and so they'll
have a better idea of what to expect for
the warm ups and so that they'll
probably be able to give you some
guidance there one thing that I would
recommend is it's not a bad idea to be
warmed up a little too early it's
certainly better to be warmed up too
early than too late you don't want to be
hitting your last warm-up attempt you
know 90 seconds before you're about to
go hit your opener so something that can
help is you know if you think your
flights about to start in 30 minutes and
you think you're gonna need 20 minutes
to get warmed up go ahead and start
warming up you know 30 or 40 minutes
before you think you're actually going
to have to lift and then if you hit your
last opener and it's still or you hit
your last warm-up and it's still 10
minutes before you're gonna hit your
opener it's easy to stay warm so if it's
gonna be 10 minutes like 5 minutes
before you're about
go hitch or open or just hit your last
warm-up again and that'll be fine
that'll keep you warm that'll keep the
groove fresh especially if you're
picking conservative openers which again
you should be if you're opening at say
85% of your max and your last warm-up is
80% of your max for a single you can hit
80% for another single and that's not
gonna fatigue you that's not gonna
affect your subsequent performance on
the platform so yeah if someone can take
you under their wing and kind of tell
you like hey here's what to expect for
the warm ups of this meet that is ideal
but then if you have to err on the side
of being warmed up too early or too late
make it too early and another thing is
like even though it may be a little bit
intimidating in the warm-up room if it's
your first meet and maybe a lot of
people are stronger than you you still
need to be assertive to get your
equipment you know the the thing about
plates is they have the little holes in
them that lets you slide them on and off
the bar if everyone else is squatting
315 and your first warm-up is 135 you go
up to them and say look I need to take
135 I'm coming up in this next flight
you are stronger than me but my lifts
matter just as much as yours let me in
on the equipment let me warm up you and
and that's another reason why it's good
to kind of make friends early in the day
because if you're afraid of being
assertive like I've done this for like
teenage lifters a bunch it meets like
you know we get to know each other early
in the day I find out it's their first
their first meet they're intimidated to
like go tell older larger people like
hey I need to get on this equipment with
you and I can just go over and be like
hey dude let let this guy work in so if
you don't have something like that you
you probably will need to be a little
assertive too to get access to the
equipment you need to warm up so that's
something to be prepared for as well so
Greg you know how sometimes people like
develop something resembling expertise
in like one or two areas and then it
like freaks them out and they decide
they shouldn't have an opinion about
anything else sure so I kind of just did
that to myself I kind of forgot that
I've been coaching a powerlifting team
in person for the last six years
I was like you know I'm standing next to
a guy that squats like 700 I should just
shut up and then like halfway through
your answer I was like wait a minute
every single summer I bring a whole
group of guys to their first
powerlifting me--never
so the things that always trip us up
obviously you you hit them all in for
context it's a Special Olympics
powerlifting team so there are some
other challenges that we kind of work
through in the competition process but
the things that get us that are very
generalizable to anyone doing their
first meet would be the equipment stuff
is brutal you got to check in with the
Federation before it they'll all have
their information online that you can
check and it's it's never a bad idea
with your openers get something that you
can just so easily bury on the squat
super deep as deep as any judge would
want you to go and something that you
could just lay it on your chest and
press it you know so once you set your
your openers you got nowhere to go but
up from there so you got to be you got
to give yourself a little bit of room to
to at least get something on the board
for sure all right Eric next question
for you is from C
Fiorella asking about textbooks so in a
previous episode of the podcast we've
recommended buying in X phys textbook
one of the things you'll see when you
look around and you're you're trying to
buy a textbook is that the newest
current editions of textbooks are really
expensive
unjustifiably so those blood-sucking
publishers are the worst but anyway new
textbooks are very expensive older
editions you know maybe published 10
years ago maybe 15 years ago you can
pick up used really really cheap so
obviously science is advancing the field
is learning new things so this question
is basically asking what are you missing
out on by not buying the newest edition
of a textbook and are you probably going
to be fine saving some money and just
going with with an older edition yeah so
this is a really good question
Gregg and I in the past have have both
said on the show how enthusiastic we are
about recommending that people do pick
up a textbook and work their way through
it and one of the things that Gregg and
I also share is a personality that
couldn't possibly allow us to spend like
$200 on an exercise textbook it's like
come on that's crazy like they get so
expensive it's just wild it's completely
outrageous yeah so honestly I don't even
know if they go for 200 I haven't even
looked at the price of a new hardcover
textbook because it's so far off the
realistic table of possibilities of
things I would buy I like we don't even
look into it so what I always recommend
to people is go find like one or two
editions old so I wouldn't say like yeah
get one that's like five or six editions
behind because one of the great things
about science is that it does grow and
evolve and change we learn more over
time but we don't do it that quickly and
so it kind of comes to the general
premise of what exactly is this textbook
for I would say the the the premise of
recommending that you go check out a
textbook is not to receive the cutting
edge absolutely brand-new hot off the
presses research of the day in and
frankly even if that's why you're doing
it you're not gonna get it when we were
talking in our interview with Lauren
Collins Oh simple we were talking about
how there's a lot of information about
fiber types that just hasn't made its
way in yet yeah that was actually one of
the few things I would say has has
changed in the most recent edition of
some textbooks but wouldn't be in older
textbooks like some of the the fiber
typing stuff yes so there are but but
even at the time that some of the
slightly older editions were were
printed it was like the research was
kind of there but they weren't ready to
really make their way into the textbooks
yet right yeah what I'm getting at is
there is some lag time correct where
like even when you buy the new textbook
it's probably even still just a tiny
a bit behind where where we truly are in
terms of the cutting-edge research for
sure in a lot of cases but in any case
the reason that we recommend looking at
a textbook is really to help establish
basically a baseline background
theoretical knowledge of the field the
really key concepts that have basically
been more or less ingrained for more
than a handful of years so this is to
establish a baseline knowledge in how
the muscles work how does metabolism
work really basic stuff to help get a
firm foundation of your knowledge in the
field not only firm but also
comprehensive make yourself work your
way through not just the stuff you want
to know so how does the muscle work but
also how does you know metabolism and
bioenergetics relate to how muscle works
how do you know the respiratory systems
and the cardiovascular systems relate to
each other because what you'll find I
kind of had a project idea a million
years back that it didn't really work
out but I was like what if I just kind
of threw together like something
resembling a textbook it was a bad idea
I don't know why I thought that was cool
but one of the really challenging things
is deciding where to start because all
of the different chapters of a textbook
are so inherently interrelated for sure
to some degree so like it's hard to
explain the cardiovascular system
without the respiratory system and it's
hard to explain how muscles work without
the bioenergetic piece and you have to
kind of figure out in what order do I
even approach this and honestly when I
review text books like talking with
friends about which ones we liked or
disliked it basically comes down to who
had the most creative way to tackle the
problem of what order do we discuss this
in which you and I disagree extremely on
up about Brooks
yeah the George Brooks textbook I I
think to this day I still contend has a
lot of extremely good information but
the order of it I just can't get past it
doesn't work for me so at this point the
show has officially jumped the shark
because we're doing we're doing reviews
of a
ticular advanced physiology textbook
that no one listening to this is ever
going to read so the the thing I like
about Brooks is like I think the depth
and quality of information is truly
exceptional I'm like a textbook resource
and I think that it would make just an
utterly [ __ ]
first exercise physiology textbook yeah
but since it's not intended to be that
since it is like a graduate level X phys
text I think that it can get away with
worse organization because you should
come in knowing probably 60 to 70% of
the information in the textbook and it's
just like topping you off on that last
little bit you know absolutely so I
think that's a good gentle reminder to
get back on track so the reason that
you're looking for this textbook is not
to get the cutting-edge research it's to
establish your foundation of theoretical
knowledge in the field and that theory
is derived by years and years and
decades of research on the key
foundational topics and what this is
gonna do for you is it's gonna give you
a nice line of defense against when
someone tries to sell you something
stupid or tell you about some stupid
training strategy and you say no no no I
understand the actual foundational
concepts here that doesn't sound like it
makes any sense whatsoever
usually even just kind of a baseline
level of that based on stuff that we
knew to be true by 1995 it's gonna be
enough to arm you against a lot of those
types of claims and products that just
don't make any sense another thing it
does is it gives you a base of
information for making future decisions
about things that aren't even thought of
yet so when some new supplement comes
out when some new training contraption
or training method comes out really the
first line of defense for that is based
on foundational concepts of how exercise
physiology works do I have any reason to
believe that that's plausible and so a
textbook is what's gonna help you with
those things not you know is every line
of this thing gospel and completely up
to date and so for that reason I do
recommend go one addition two additions
maybe three additions old but then I'm
starting to get a little bit
uncomfortable but one or two additions
old you're going to
pay a fraction of the cost you're going
to get a an enormous percentage of the
benefit from it and you're probably not
gonna be missing out on too much so yeah
I do think one of the big benefits of
textbooks is just the the degree to
which they are comprehensive so like
they're they're broad but not super deep
but that's totally fine because because
like Eric was getting that there's I
think it's underappreciated how
interconnected all of physiology is and
so if you're if you're like us and
you're you know into power lifting or
bodybuilding and you know mainly just
want to get jacked and or strong if you
open a physiology textbook you know
you're probably just going to jump
you're probably gonna look at the index
and see what is the skeletal muscle
chapter and then jump straight to that
but everything is so incredibly
interconnected so if you don't know
about metabolism then it's like oh we're
you know we're oxidizing carbohydrate
and fat but how is that stuff actually
getting delivered to the muscle and how
does that delivery work during exercise
and how is it regulated you may not care
at all about learning about the kidneys
but that's where most of the electrolyte
regulation goes on and so when you learn
about excitation contraction coupling
and how sodium like the sodium and
potassium gradients are super important
for depolarization of the sarcolemma
like that stuff working properly is
largely down to the kidneys when you
learn about how acidosis can affect
fatigue of the muscles that's going to
be regulated by both the kidneys and the
lungs so it's worth knowing how that
works and so you know maybe if you have
a little bit of pulmonary edema that's
going to compromise exercise capacity
because it induces some acidosis you
know obviously important to learn about
the heart to see how all of this stuff
is delivered to the muscles in the first
place and how cardiac output is affected
by different forms of exercise and
exercise intensity learning about the
autonomic nervous system to get an idea
of how like blood shunting works to to
deliver blood to the active muscles and
not systemically like
all of these things work together and so
by the time you get down to you know
doing a binge press there's a tremendous
amount of stuff that has gone on to put
your body into a position where it can
do that and it's all incredibly under
interconnected and maybe if you're
having issues with something I mean
unless it's like something clinical it
is probably going to be like neural or
muscular but like there there are a lot
of different systems that affect how
exercise performance works and how
muscles function and you can't you can't
fully understand muscle unless you have
at least a decent understanding of lungs
or kidneys or livers or any of the rest
of it it's it's all incredibly
interconnected and you'll get that from
a textbook if you actually force
yourself to sit down and read the whole
thing and it's it's hard to get that
breadth of understanding from pretty
much any other source yeah and you
mentioned that people are likely to just
say okay let's skip to the skeletal
muscle stuff very brief anecdote grad
students always give guest lectures like
if a faculty member has to go on a trip
they're you know gonna take vacation go
travel for work whatever but you know
they'll go to the grad students say hey
come teach my class for a day I'm going
and it was like three of us sitting
around we're all PhD students between
the three of us we had done like seven
recent guest lectures and it was like
six of those were pulmonary and one was
renal and like we very quickly realized
every X phys professor if they basically
wait to teach about the lungs or the
kidneys until they're on vacation like
even at the highest levels of the field
nobody wants to deal with that but it's
still very important and the textbooks
where you get it one last thing before
we move on George Brooks is an absolute
legend the stuff he's done with lactate
metabolism is remarkable but I think you
should have rearranged the chapters I'm
sorry okay so we got one last question
the question was what are the best ways
to increase quad size and strength to
how
Pinilla extensors in the squat and so
basically the way I'm interpreting this
question is what are your favorite quad
exercises is that fair enough
yeah I think so how about you start here
and then I'll I'll come in yeah so I
tend to be fairly simple with exercise
selection but I do have a couple little
tweaks that I like to make to some of
them
um so obviously if you're talking quads
front squat and back squat are gonna be
nice I mean front squat is exquisite for
the quads because it's just for me
remarkably quad heavy dumbbell Bulgarian
split squat is nice but I really like to
do it with holding just a single
dumbbell for whatever reason I tend to
be able to balance way better if I do
just a dumbbell held in the hand of the
active leg the leg that's actually
squatting which is kind of a typical but
so like if if my right foots up on a
bench and I'm squatting with the left
leg
I'll hold only a dumbbell in my left
hand and extend my right hand out for
counter balancing and for whatever
reason for me that is just the sweet
spot of being able to just focus in not
worry about balance and drive through
that quad I like walking lunges I tend
to get plenty for the quad out of that I
know some people depending on their
stride length can kind of shift that
focus to other muscle groups unilateral
leg extension machine
I love turning that into a unilateral
exercise even if it's not set up for
that to me it's just it's so much better
when I can really focus on making sure
that the you know I'm focusing and kind
of manipulating my body's positioning to
make sure it's just perfect application
of that force for the each individual
quad and another thing I like to do Greg
you and I've talked about this for
whatever reason we both grew up near
gyms that had the just this beautiful
hammer strength horizontal leg press
with a slightly tilted foot platform and
that machine is wild and I do that and
unilateral fashion as well and I'm
actually pretty upset because I used to
love that machine I no longer have
access to it and it was just my favorite
thing in the world and then finally you
can't have this discussion without
talking about the the traditional hack
squat machine with the load positioned
over the shoulders I don't I don't like
the the kind of newer generation that
they're called hack squats but it's it's
like you're the load is more situated
near the hips yeah I it like puts you
into like some pretty serious lumbar
flexion as like a starting point I'm not
a big fan of that I like the traditional
you know at an angle weight on the
shoulders hack squat I I agree with all
of those for the most part so if the the
way this question was asked is what are
the best exercises for increasing quad
size specifically for the squat and so
the way I'm looking at this is like if
you're if if you don't have another
muscle group that's limiting you just
squat like do some form of squat you're
not going to be able to train your quads
specifically for the squat better than
you can with the squat and so then when
I start thinking about accessory
exercises I'm approaching it with with
that context in mind that basically this
person needs more quad work than they
can get from the squat which could be
for for a couple different reasons one
maybe someone has some sort of back
issue or some sort of hip issue that
just limits the amount of weekly
squatting volume they can do for for
some other reason or maybe this person
just just naturally has a crazy hip
dominant squat and subjectively doesn't
feel like they get much quad stimulation
from doing squats and you know have a
relative dearth of quad development to
back up that subjective feeling so under
those circumstances I'm thinking about
what exercises can we do that's going to
take a fair amount of spinal or hip
loading out of the equation so we can
we focus in on the quads in situations
where people can't just get the quad
work they need from squatting and so
oftentimes for the super super quad
dominant squatters I agree with Eric's
recommendation to do front squats
because basically if you start putting
yourself in a hip dominant position for
front squats you just dump the bar and
so it forces you to stay more upright
and have more forward knee travel so
front squats can have a lot of utility
for those folks
I personally so in working with power
lifters I've often found that dumbbell
split squats are pretty iffy just
because by the time you get strong
enough your grip is going to limit you
before your quads do so I find that you
may not necessarily want to do like
barbell like back squat position lunges
because then if you start losing your
balance things get really dicey really
quick but you can just do those those
split squats or lunges with a barbell in
the front rack position and one that's
going to keep you honest for the same
reason front squats do you have to be
pretty upright and focusing more on your
quads instead of letting yourself hinge
forward and maybe getting your hip
extensors into the movement a little bit
more just by virtue of the barbell being
in the front rack position and that also
lets you load it a little bit heavier
without grip being a limiter so I do I
do like split squats and lunges but
generally more with a barbell and a
front rack position versus dumbbells
with the walking lunges I also think
they're awesome and I think that they're
best done with bodyweight for crazy high
reps I don't know why but I think just
like you know 200 yards straight of
walking lunges even if form starts
getting iffy by the end and like range
of motion starts getting really
compromised if like the quad burns
started at 50 meters in and you're going
200 meters I don't care like that's
still that's going to to clobber the
[ __ ] out of your quads and I I just the
bro and me things that's awesome
that's something I did really early in
my training career I felt like I got a
lot of quad growth out of it still to
this day if maybe like my back or hips
are a little janky and I just want to
clobber the [ __ ] out of my quads it's
like okay well let's find a sidewalk
where there's not going to be that many
people walking or driving who will see
how ridiculous I look and I'm just gonna
do walking lunges until I hate myself
and then I also really really strongly
agree with the hack squat suggestion
there is still probably going to be some
degree of spinal loading just because
you know the the if it's a good hack
squat machine and the weight is pressing
down on the shoulder pads into you it is
still probably going to be some level of
loading for the spine but it it's not
gonna be probably as stressful as like
barbell back squats will be and you can
just get really deep into it really
really largely isolate your quads much
better than you would be able to with
leg press hack squats bothers some
people's knees so you know play it by
ear
if hack squats don't feel good for you
don't do them yeah those would be my
recommendations as well and also belt
squats if you have a gym that has a belt
squat machine which which I know is
pretty uncommon but if your gym does
have a belt squat machine belt squats
are great too alright I think that does
it for this Q&A episode before we leave
I do want to make a quick announcement
Andy Morgan if you're listening I know
you are please stop texting me about
keeping Greg knuckles as a permanent
co-host Andy you might know him from the
the biggest fitness site in Japan I
believe is that right Greg yeah also a
co-author of the the muscle and strength
pyramid books with Eric Helms right yeah
now the number one best-selling health
and fitness book in Spain there's a
third author on that right Andrea Valdez
yes yes so yeah Andy has messed that
messaged me three times in the last 24
hours to keep you on as a permanent host
two of them happened exactly twelve
hours apart and I know for a fact he has
a
alarm set yeah he sent me a video of him
setting alarms god I love her money and
I'm starting to think that he is the
head of the whole troll farm operation
that seems to be messaging me non-stop
about keeping you around it's simply
just not a possibility okay so everyone
save your time especially Andy call off
all the people you've put up to this it
has to stop okay as always thank you so
much for listening we'll see you next
time thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com to
check out the products and services that
we offer thanks for listening and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you